before we start I just wanted to remind
everyone that this afternoon we have the
open problem session and you can sign up
either through this short URL where you
get on you know okay so the first okay
thanks for setting the stage okay so I
think a good starting point for this
talk is explaining the title right so
this is joint work with Burroughs
Gurbani and Hamid jawad you are two
students in stem four right so let me
start by explaining the title so what is
topic models topic
so this is a popular way of modeling you
know datasets that are formed for
instance of documents x1 x2 so these are
representing as vectors in some high
dimensional space and and the idea is
that each of these documents is a
mixture for the mixture of topics X
tilde 1 H tilde K and these are also
vector in R T so think for instance that
these are word counts for a dictionary
in documents in a certain corpus and the
way the way you notice this mixture is
is constructed is as follows I construct
a matrix that is a matrix whose rows has
the vector X 1 to X n so this is a
matrix that is and by D and then I
declare the Takeda's matrix is generated
as okay some coefficient that are called
square root of DT over D times W H
transpose plus Z so here W is a matrix W
1 W n so it's a skinny matrix this is K
and this is N and each of these WI is is
just a probability vector okay so W IJ
sum over J is 1 and W IJ is no negative
and and this matrix H are also bright
for for the rows of H h1 to HD ok and
each column of this represent a topic ok
so this is say D by K
and and you can think of Z as noise or
whatever is not is not captured by this
I you know WH transpose model okay so
this kind of model was really made
popular in particular by paper a very
well-known paper by David Bligh angry
and ruing and Michael Jordan in 2003
about latent delicious layer locations
and and what did they introduce one main
idea of the paper was to introduce a
probabilistic model a Bayesian model for
for the weights and in particular the
main assumption there that the main idea
there was that the weights WI so the
rows of this were iid deliciously
with some parameter mu okay so the
directional distribution is a product
distribution of a probability vectors in
K dimension is parameterized by your K
parameters and you want to Nu K okay so
here I will simplify little bit the
model of of Bly England Jordan for being
able to do a bit more calculations so in
particular take this parameters mu to be
all equals
so nu the vector new to be new blah blah
blah new so all the parameters of the
dalish layer equal so in particular the
density of the reader shall i data
indicate by q0 of w is basically apart
from a constant is the product over i 1
to k wi to the Nu minus 1 times the
indicator function of W being a
probability vector in a dimension right
and the second simplification and I'll
make okay if you think of what I was my
motivation this matrix ax is a matrix of
what counts so this should be integer
should be
negative integers here I'll do something
a bit simpler I'll take this this X to
be real and the matrix the the columns
of H or the entries of age to be iid
normal so the prior that'll put of H is
very simple is normal and and also the
noise my nose will also be Gaussian of
course the original model the noise is
Poisson okay but I'll okay
as you'll see I don't think this this
really changes much things when the
question in this in this problem is of
course given water ization of of this of
this matrix act estimate estimate the
factors H and W so the factors H gives
you the topics and W the compositions of
the documents in two topics and and
starting with this paper indeed or one
metadata that became very popular was
was called variational inference
okay so this explains other part of the
title so explain what topic mothers are
what is variational inference well the
idea is I want to minimize I want to do
base Bayesian inference I want to
excavate the posterior of H and W given
observation X but I want to translate
this into an optimization problem so
instead of you know doing Monte Carlo
for instance I can write I want to write
it as a minimization problem and the way
I do it I will try to minimize the could
battle I blur divergence between a
probability distribution Q hat and the
posterior of H and W given X now this is
an optimization problem that is an
optimization problem in extremely high
dimensional space because Q is a
probability distribution over you know
all of these of these numbers so it's
exponentially large but you minimize it
over a restricted set of probability
distribution you minimize it over a
probability distribution that takes the
form q HW equal product I want to D of Q
I of H I product a 1 to n u tilde a of W
a we say I cannot possibly you know do
an solve an optimization problem over a
space of exponentially many dimension a
restrict only on probability
distribution that factorize over the
rows of H and the rows of W ok so this
is the assumption once you write it in
this way ok the other observation you
notice is that this kullback-leibler
Devon just can be computed apart from
constants
so these takes the following form is you
know the expectation with respect to Q
hat of log of Q hat of H and W minus the
expectation respect to Q eight of log
log of P of X given H and W minus the
expectation respect to Q hat of log pH
minus the expectation with respect to Q
hat of log PW plus constant and all of
these are things that once you have a
handle in particular if you take Q 8 to
be factorized all of these are things
that you can can compute the constant is
the logarithm of P of X this is
something that you can compute but all
the other terms are object that you can
compute and now you will get an
objective function that is very nice I
mean it's not very nice it's it's it's
non convex but but if you can minimize
it and if this assumption is good it
holds the promise of translating the
Bayesian optimization problem into an
optimization problem so the problem of
computing the marginals into the problem
of solving optimization problem there is
this clear more or less or is it clear
so this is you know very short
introduction to topic models and to
variational inference so the way they
minimize this then is basically they do
alternate minimization you notice the
disease convex in the queue and convex
in the Q hat and so you minimize with
respect to the Q and then you minimize
with respect to Q hat and your terminate
okay
so minimize the
by alternate so you minimize with
respect to the Q and the Q hat etc let's
keep it okay okay so right here alright
so the question is the question that why
I want to to answer is does it work and
to explain to explain the the the work
actually so this is based on a paper
that we are we are sure hopefully we'll
be out in a couple of win weeks I
decided that I will explain a simpler
example once you understand what happens
in this example it should be clear what
is the result in general it's more
complicated to do calculations but but
basically the same phenomena and simpler
example is this z2 sink model so what is
this model is very simple to model you
have a matrix that you observe and this
is a rank one matrix plus noise the
noise is a matrix W matrix W that has n
3w III so this is a matrix n by n the
matrix WS n 3i ad normal 0 2 over n on
the diagonal and out of the diagonal
normal 0 1 over n an important thing is
that the vector Sigma is a plus minus 1
vector ok so a lot is known about so the
problem here is you're given a
realization of xn we want to estimate
Sigma ok and you know it's a very you
know it's a much simpler than this of
course because the distribute
one of the factors is very simple but
bear some resemblance is there low rank
matrix plus some noise so problem Sigma
from you don't want to put this in a
Bayesian framework yeah
so the distribution of Sigma is uniform
over the hypercube and and yeah and the
observation is just what I said so what
is the optimal accuracy so this is well
known it's well known in this model what
is the optimal weight the optimal error
that you can achieve in on Sigma when
when n goes to infinity and this was was
solved in two papers or there is word
paper that is explained in different
language and it doesn't talk about
estimation but basically contains some
many of the results and then is there is
a paper with joshdosh ponding and and
something that you can prove or a
corollary of this of this of these two
papers is the following lemma for any
this is actually can be proved even much
easier for any Sigma hat for any
estimator Sigma so this is something
that takes matrices and spits out
vectors if lambda less or equal than 1
then Lim soup and to infinity Sigma hat
of X Sigma
the bus is a Sigma Sigma okay so this
lemma is saying the following
you give me any estimator any possible
algorithm and compute the correlation
with the truth when n goes to infinity
this is asymptotically decorrelated
asymptotically orthogonal to the true
vector so you cannot achieve anything
known to be real so now we know and with
vice versa this is tight in the sense
that for lambda bigger than one it's
easy to show that that you can achieve
positive positivity but for this for
this talk I only need this very simple
fact okay now let's try to do
variational inference on this model okay
what this means following what I was
saying here what this means I take a
posterior u Sigma postulated posterior
and assume that this factorizes so now
one nice thing about now the
distribution plus minus 1 that the fact
that the Sigma's are plus minus 1 is
that each of these marginals is actually
a one dimensional object is
parameterized by one number its
expectation so I'll parameterize it by
the expectation so Qi of Sigma is 1 plus
mi over 2 so i parameterize this one
dimension with two-dimensional
distribution by by this number M I now
if you do a little calculation obtaining
that your subject you had the KL
divergence between Q hat and P of Sigma
given X
is equal to some fun of course is equal
to some function of M plus constant and
the function of M you can write it
explicitly it's 1 plus Sigma yeah yeah
okay plus 1 thank you
okay so this function is very simple is
is minus lambda over 2m X 0 and minus
sum over I 1 to n H of a my where well
XD what is X 0 is basically X where I
put the diagonal equal to 0 ok so I
replace the diagram doesn't really
matter but the diagonal is replaced by
zeros and then H is just the entropy
function each of em is simply minus
minus 1 plus X over 2 log 1 plus X over
2 minus 1 minus x over 2 log so this is
just your tree line calculation from
this definition you plug in these
answers and you get this this free
energy scale divergence
so of course this is the first piece so
this is a nice function right it makes a
lot of sense the first piece is
basically the maximum likelihood
objective when you were you just
replaced the plus minus one variable
with variables in the interval 0 1 and
then this is a kind of entropy
penalisation and notice that the maximum
likelihood has a weight lambda in front
of it which means if the signal is very
strong go with the maximum likelihood
and then instead if the signal is weak
you should go towards 0 this is maxima
minimized when all them are equal to 0
so by the uniform posterior so this
piece makes a lot of sense since when
the signal is not strong just reply no
estimate everything with zero so this
thing makes sense
so you
you want to minimize it over plus minus
1/2 the Emma and what you expect is that
for lambda less or equal than 1 in view
of this lamina posterior
approximately uniform so this is the
intuition this lemma says if this is a
good approximation for lambda smaller
the posterior should be uniform because
no estimator can can tell me anything
that is positive correlation right okay
so you start doing calculation and the
first thing that you notice is that if I
look at the point zero so this is just
the center of the upper cube this is a
stationary point it's a critical point
so it's critical point science in the
sense that if you look at the gradient
of this item star it's always equal to
zero so you can call this the
uninformative
stationary point the uninformative
critical point this is saying you know
it's a critical point of this free
energy that is telling ok I have no
information about the system so so you
computed the gradient but ok you took
calculus so you can compute also the
action I took a calculus computation you
get this very simple right this is
quadratic and this is a separable
function you have just computed the the
second derivative of this function at x
equals zero that is not difficult this
one so this comes from this piece and
this comes from this piece ok so this is
basically these zero setting things to
zero on the diagonal it doesn't really
matter it's negligible if I replace it
with with the realloc right and now of
course you want to check whether the
action is positive semi-definite or not
right
now the nice thing is that I know pretty
much everything about this the spectrum
of about desmet of this matrix X this is
something that is being studied in
thousands now in hundreds of papers in
probability theory and one thing that is
known is this phase transition
phenomenon that if you look at lambda
max of this matrix X s so this is a Rank
1 deformation of a Wigner matrix this is
2 if lambda is smaller or equal than 1
and lambda plus lambda minus 1 otherwise
so you substitute there and you obtain
that limp and to infinity of the minimum
guy what is interesting is the minimum
because we want to understand whether
this is really a minimum or not this is
this is what is 1 minus 2 lambda if
lambda less or equal than 1 the minus
lambda square otherwise
aha something is happening what's
happening something troubling is
happening here
what's happening here is that when
lambda crosses 1/2 this is becoming
negative right so M star becomes
unstable
for lambda bigger than 1/2 okay
and so okay now you can you can do a
little little proposition this is really
all elementary for lambda bigger than
1/2 any without probability any local
any local mean of F M hat has one over n
norm M had bigger or equal than a
constant so for lambda bigger than 1/2
you know if you try to minimize this
free energy you get something that is
pretty far from zero on average all the
entries of M hat will be of order 1 so
it's telling you that the posterior okay
so this means that if you do variational
inference the posterior is telling you
this is not uniform I have a signal
but then hat where if well in what
direction will be will be in that
direction that is completely
uncorrelated with true vector because we
have this lemma that tells us that
cannot be possibly correlated with true
vector so between 1/2 and one if you
solve variational inference what
aberrational inference is tell you is I
believe that there is a signal but the
estimate that gives you it gives you is
pure garbage
okay so now I could more or less finish
the talk here let me add song here
[Music]
so same happens for topic models so the
calculation is more complicated a little
bit but I don't know where is the global
minimum but of course of course you know
this is true for any local me so a
global minimum in my in my sense of my
interpretation it's a it's also local
minimums but yeah this is what I'm
saying
even if you are able to I don't know if
you are able to optimize that's a
difficult problem can you optimize this
non convex function I don't know frankly
but I can tell you this that even if you
are optimized it optimally you get
garbage out of it in this interval of
lambda of course if lambda is very large
in this simple model then you will get a
good signal but it's lambda is very
large you can do pretty much anything
yeah so the problem is yeah of course
it's design sets your message here is
that if lenses between one half and when
your message is really about one limb
does be doin what happened wrong what
you're saying is that you have a
procedure that seems to indicate that
their signal when there's really not
right right okay so what happens when
lambda is lower than one because okay it
gives you garbage but why would you
trust it lambda is less than one anyway
yeah if you have aerial data set you
don't know if lambda is bigger than 1 or
lambda you run it you get announcer okay
so okay so yeah of course in this model
that is and of course actually in this
model there is a procedure for instance
in this paper that gives you the Bayes
optimal estimate up to your relative X
so it gives you the Bayes optimal and
your scalar per product for instance or
the Bayes optimal mean square error okay
for lambda less than one is zero so
there is a procedure that for lambda
less than one achieves this and for
lambda bigger than one achieved the best
that you can achieve I cannot tell you I
can render yadda I don't know but for
lambda big enough you would expect that
it works right now what happens so
bigger than a constant what happens
between one there then big constant I
don't know
right but I would expect this that
lambda is 1 plus Epsilon it will still
be you know pretty much uncorrelated
right or or it will be not particularly
good if M is less than 1 is there a
procedure that actually says hey I
actually have garbage weight well you
can if the model is true you can for
instance tested the largest eigenvalue
of the matrix okay
adult and and you test it again too if
it is smaller than two I mean if it is
smaller than two up so you say there is
no signal steer and true so it's true
that's what's the underlying reason
because we know that's below the
critical thresholds the keeps measure
will decompose into okay so this is
start to be tricky and this has to do
with so it's true that is asymptotically
separable so this statement so what this
statement is not true in this form but
isn't true in the weaker form or is
expected in the sense that you know if
you look at finite dimensional marginals
so joint marginals of any k subset of
variables this is asymptotically true
but now if you compute this so you will
say okay this is sufficient for
computing this object is true but the
correlations gives a correction term so
this is what appears in the top free
energy so you know what these things are
and in fact you know if you do with the
top free energy then it becomes stable
okay any other question so perhaps it
perhaps let me let me briefly talk about
what happens with the with the topic
models
okay so first first step so let's try to
do the same calculation that we did here
so I will not do the whole calculation
information theoretic limit
so these have been studied recently so
there is a paper by Naomi Olin that
really applies to the setting and there
is a related work by by the large the
other so the paper that that you need is
this one and this papers ok gives you a
characterization of what are this limit
in particular you get a proposition that
has this form if beta so beta is the snr
my model was X equal square root of beta
over D I think W and H transpose plus
said okay so if beta is less than a
certain threshold beta B's bullet of K
Delta then for any estimator age for any
H hat w hat limit the n goes to infinity
so here I'm look at the N goes to
infinity so D and then R the dimension
of this matrix with the Oberon n over D
equal Delta fixed ok so in this limit if
you look at write it and then I explain
what this is
look at the correlation between the
purpose oh so this matrix for this
matrix is a matrix that is n by K I act
out the constant the constant vector so
for instance each perpendicular means H
P perpendicular where P perpendicular is
identity minus 1 over K 1 1 transpose so
I subtract from each row the sum of that
row this is completely uninformative or
the sum of it it sure is just a you know
a dummy quantity and this is 0 below the
threshold and similar for W
now this distraction that's given in
business this by applying these theorems
is actually you know as a kind of
complicated form but we look at two
cases in which it is simple for K in two
and three and u equal one and one-half
so these are the cases that we studied
we find that this threshold is equal to
the threshold of what would be the the
spectral method for this problem so this
is a simple formula K K nu minus plus 1
divided by square root of Delta so this
is the first component gives you the
equivalent of the lambda equal one
threshold the second component is
generalizing the variational inference
algorithm
so I will not go again in detail but
turns out that this is simplified
because okay again as I said before okay
we assume this the composition and and
this this factor stakes take a simple
form this Qi of a try is really e to the
H I minus 1/2 times Q 0 of H i where
this is the prior so you know basically
the posterior at any you prove that at
any stationary point of the of the KL
divergence the posterior or the your
belief is equal to the prior times
basically Gaussian density where mi is
related to the mean of this density and
Q is a K by K matrix that gives the
covariance of this density and the same
for the factor on the weights okay so
this is e to the some M tilde W a minus
1/2 W a q tilde wa0 OWA where this is
the directly prior ok so this is the
Gaussian prior
and this is the direction I hire
so once you have design sets and you
have this form the optimization you can
see that the optimization problems
reduces to an optimization problem over
this vector SEM I and these matrices Q
okay so you write your your k KL
divergence okay this is your KL
divergence as of Q hat and WH given X as
some function log of some constant that
is log of the probability of of the data
plus some function of what M tilde Q so
these are matrices basically these are
the set of all these vectors M I so
these are matrices in N by K this is a
matrix in D by K these are matrixes in K
by K so I will not write this this this
formula because it's a bit messy but but
can be written and and the variational
inference algorithm is simply doing
alternate minimization so you minimize
with respect to M Q and then with
respect to M tilde Q tilde so what
happens with this algorithm
okay so first of all it has an AM
uninformative fixed point so there exist
a fixed point of the former okay let's
say M star is equal to a constant times
X times the old one vector times 1
transpose and M equal until the star
equal some constant times X T x11 okay
and Q star equal Q 1 times identity plus
Q 2 J and the same for Q T of the star
so this point is an informative in the
sense that has all columns equal so it
doesn't distinguish at all between the
cake topics so this is a thing that is
telling telling to you basic basically
all the topics are the same topics so
it's answering basically the mean of all
the rows of X it's giving you the means
of all the rows of X so this is a
completely uninformative
the point our stationary point fixed
point I'm in a really critical point
okay and then and then the following the
main calculation is computing the action
of this guy and checking when it becomes
negative and okay so I will not give the
formula but there exist a formula that
depends on beta K Delta Nu some explicit
space such that the following happens if
L is bigger than one then if you look at
the action of this function at the
critical points the uninformative fixed
point this is not just one but in fact
theta of n negative eigenvalues then
with that probability
so this gives you the instability point
of this of this variational inference
algorithm and this is also of course an
instability of the alternated
minimization procedure okay so you can
define a bita instability that is the
smallest beta at this at which this
happens the smallest signal-to-noise
ratio which this happens so this is
function of K nu and Delta and the
remark is that okay this is an explicit
formula you evaluate it you compare it
with beta the best formula the best
threshold and this is below so in this
interval variational inferences is doing
the same as it was doing in the z2
synchronization problem is giving an
output that is of course uncorrelated
with the truth but is far from being
uniform
okay so so in the last 15 minutes what
I'll do is just to give some I'll show
how this this instability shows up
numerically but but you know final
remark you can modify so this is
something that came up a little bit
before you can modify this this mean
feel free energy so this this factorized
approximation and obtain a better so
this this factorized form is what's
called normally named me field you can
refine it or you can improve it and get
something that is called the talus under
some Palmer free energy and get
something that that has a better
behavior and and the doesn't doesn't
seem to have the same instability okay
so this is seems to be Stabler
that's true for just a beginning two or
three maybe not more right da what sense
so in yeah okay so for all the cases
that we checked so this has doesn't have
an instability okay so I will not state
formally the result but doesn't have
instability before the spectre of
threshold when the last our props 15
minutes I show out this this result
shows in in simulations
so I wanted to do simulations and here I
do simulations assuming that the model
is correct right as you know the indole
calculation I assume that I generate
synthetic data with the correct model
and I want to answer two questions first
does variational inference converge to
the uninformative fixed point so what we
do is something very simple
we initialize next to you know close to
this an informative fixed point we run
variational inference we get to estimate
of the factors and then we compute the
distance from the uninformative subspace
so I'll do simulations just for k equal
to for simplicity and and in this case
the distance from the uninformative
fixed set point is what is just the
difference between the two columns okay
if the two columns are equal of W means
that basically it's answering all that
one half right so if two columns of the
it's am sorry that the each document
splits one-half one-half on other ways
the same for the topic the two topics
are equal you know they don't contain
any information and this is this is a
small team you know thousand matrix with
various values of Delta and this is the
the beta the signal noise noise ratio
and this is the distance from this
uninformative subspace that you converge
to so we run for many Terry ation we
have a convergent criteria see what you
get one of these is for H this is for H
and this is for W so for beta small you
know variational inference behave
correctly it outputs you you know
something and informative but above beta
and this point is something around three
they start becoming different from zero
and here is very different from zero and
this is the worth this vertical line is
the instability that we computed so the
point at which this this formula L
becomes bigger than one and this is the
threshold for the base estimation
and this is basically the same the same
kind of simulations in which in a two
dimensional plane I plot a plot you know
we repeat this for four hundred
instances for every point in a grid of
values of Delta and beta and we look at
the fraction of instances such that this
distance is bigger than ten to the minus
four and yo on one side of this
instability line this is this fraction
of hysteresis is zero and on the other
side of this instability line that is
this black line this fraction of
instances is one so as soon as you move
on this side the operational inference
outputs something that is far from zero
and this is the line for the base
estimator the Bayes optimal estimator so
in this interval basically the rational
inference is outputting something that
is non zero but as no meaning the second
question is the output operational
inference positively correlated with the
truth okay
so how do we check that while again
sticking to the test k equal to look at
the or the informative component so for
instance the difference between the two
columns of the matrix H this is the
difference between the two TOC topic
whatever is non trivial and then what we
look is the correlation between this and
the true topic again in the non huh and
we have to regularize a little bit not
to get zero over zero now we want to
check whether this is zero or not of
course for small sizes this as
fluctuation and Barriss come come
continuously so what we do is one nice
way to check whether this is non zero or
not is to do this this so this is a
physics trick is called the bender
cumulant so we look at the fourth moment
the empirical fourth moment of this
correlation divided by the square of the
second moment well this is an
interesting ratio because if this is you
know asymptotically zero you expect it
to be Gaussian
roughly Gaussian with traps variance
small variance so the fourth moment
divided by the square of the second
moment should give three and they said
my coefficient in such a way that I get
three half minus three off so the bender
is 0 if this is non zero it should
concentrate around something non zero so
this should be roughly the same as the
square of the second moment so you get 1
by 1 3 1/2 minus 1/2 and the bean there
should be 1 so it's a nice way to start
from a transition that is no short and
getting a transition that is sharp and
this is how it behaves for this you know
simple instance these are the two two
threshold and you know this is the
instability so here things are far from
zero and then you know basically this
bender cumulant is small and starts
growing across you know grows as a
transition around around the base curve
okay and also here it has a transition
for for different values of Delta and
it's the heat map of the same quantity
so this guy start having been correlated
above the the base the baseline
okay so this is the summary for
variation on the inference you know this
is basically the same plane there is
this ratio and John in which the
correlation with the true vector is very
small but but the output operational
inferences is far from zero now we can
try to fix I didn't explain your this
top free energy but this is kind of a
different slightly improved your
operational approximation that again
relies on similarities but does
calculation better I will not go in
detail but this behaves better so the
alternate minimization of this thing the
equivalence is this approximate message
passing algorithm so it's related to two
belief propagation and this is now
behaves better in the sense that is okay
this is the norm again so the distance
between the uninformative fixed at Point
this is very small until or a fairly
small until the instead the the base
threshold again is very small until the
base threshold very small until the base
threshold and is very small until the
Bayesian result and if you plot the
the lash line is always the instability
of the variational method and this is
the base method that is also in this
case the spectral threshold for the
model okay now if you're an MP in this
case this is a phase transition so it's
small it doesn't so the non informative
fixed point seems to remain stable until
the right point and then becomes becomes
unstable at that point I'm not sure in
the following sense I'm sure in the
sense that I can do the analysis using
state evolution which corresponds to
taking and to infinity first and then
the number of iteration infinity later
so in that sense I'm sure but I'm not
sure in the sense of computing the
action okay so the same proof doesn't go
through and in the simpler case of the
z2 case you model you can check that
but now computing the action for the
topic model is a bit messy because there
are these Q by Q matrices perhaps it can
be done but we didn't yet do it and so
I'm not sure really that the minimum and
you know the the critical point of the
top free energy is really you know a
local minimum but okay to summarize
things you know we have some partial you
know rigorous evidence that this point
is stable and a numerical it seems to be
stable and this is this is you know
again the plot and you know okay some
numerical problem also with this all
correct and the correlation for this
algorithm shoot up at the right point
the the correlation with the truth shoot
up at the right point that is the Bayes
optimal threshold
and this is the same thing plotted in
two dimensions this is the the base
optimal line here the correlation with
the truth is large and here the
correlation with the truth is small as
it should be so what is the conclusion
okay my conclusion is that okay
variational inference is very successful
but I think it should be taken and it's
a very interesting idea in the sense
that it has the promise of translating a
base problem into an optimization
problem this is very interesting but it
has some problem in particular you know
in natural cases it can believe that
there is a signal where there is
actually no signal whatsoever even if
the prior is correct so yesterday where
a couple of talks about what happens if
the prior is incorrect how you robust if
I'm at your machine learning method etc
here the problem is more fundamental
even if the prior is correct things do
not work as your life - and okay you
know the last two slides I showed that
this might be fixable but of course yawn
needs much more work
Russians say I'm just to clarify what I
was wondering so since you're actually
making most of your conclusions about
the case where there's no signal what
you're actually trying to what you're
saying is correct me if I'm wrong is are
you saying that if I were to do some
posterior based inference for example
some confidence interval or something it
would actually predict some non-trivial
confidence region for Sigma I adore
where those guys are and they would be
somewhere else yeah yeah and you know so
it tells you that the the you know the
posterior for instance look at the case
the binary case right does it took case
what it tells you now now what is the
posterior in this case it's a
probability distribution on two numbers
the right posterior is this 1/2 1/2 and
1/2 Malaysia an inference tells you is
this right this is what I call wrong but
when there's no signal I mean you know
well not that nobody can prove pure
prediction perspective when nobody can
do anything it doesn't really matter is
my output is oh this thing should be all
this is a method but ok but this is a
method for unsupervised learning so
supposedly these discover structures in
data right and here we're seeing it you
know the structure that it gives is some
cases wrong so suppose that you are
trying to do clustering for instance and
does it work so it tells you a partition
of the data into two groups right in the
suitcase it gives a partition into
groups and it tells you ok I have this
confidence in this that I have this
confidence that this guy is you know a
Republican rather than a Democrat okay
and I tell you and it's much better than
then you know like maximum likelihood
because not only is telling you a
partition but is telling me on also the
confidence I'm telling the partition is
wrong and the confidence is nonsense
right so now above lambda equal one well
if lambda is large enough you know if
the model is correct you can do it
anywhere actually you can do it with
spectral methods this problem if the
model is correct
if the signal is so there is no not only
an issue
now what happens around lambda equal I
know about signal-to-noise you know the
critical signal-to-noise I cannot really
you know tell you but my guess would be
that it's not perfect or it's not as
good as you will like it's not optimized
which prior so for instance it's very
easy to see that this instability fused
the top free energy in the z2 problem
fixes it that that's very easy to
computation so the expectation is that
it fixes it always right now in the in
the in the in this topic model
distribution this is this directly prior
basically what we did this basically is
compute the state evolution and then
check that this is stable so but this is
not the full stability because this
gives you a finite number of iteration
for n goes to infinity ideally I would
like to to get the stronger result in
which you go your only computation and
compute the spectrum of the action and
check that it is PSD but that I think
it's doable but will be interesting to
the spectra when days are not the same
if the prior is different no no no I'm
not saying yeah ok but that is you know
not that relevant right I mean for this
is not that relevant but because in the
in case I'm interested in algorithm I'm
not that worried with something that is
not optimal accuracy but I'm more
worried but something that outputs a you
know a confident answer and
[Applause]